if I play Devil's Advocate it would be
cuz you never want your enemy to recover
any of your aircraft or Weaponry cuz
then they'll learn about your that's a
good Devil's Advocate so that would be
the only reason why but they just give a
to Taliban anyway they're going to give
it to anyways
[Music]
yeah do you know what F35 is part yeah
tell them it's a gy airplane yeah tell
us how cool it is how [__] Advanced
don't make that face like very cool like
very Advanced I know [__] about him
that's what I thought fool all right
very cool so this F35 Fighter Jet right
it's a fighter jet doesn't that sound
cool it sounds cool it's like got
[__] stealth technology and [__] it
sounds cool right sounds really really
cool no one can know where it's at yeah
so [__] highly Advanced right yeah
and it was on it was active and then
this particular fighter had a mishap
while they were flying in had to eject
do a little ejecto the pilot the pilo
ejected pilo pilot ejected from this
[__] so Maverick left yeah
Maverick left the plane but the [__]
stealth was still on so they couldn't
find it dude you got to do the [__]
you got to do the beep beep beep got to
turn it off did it blow up or something
35's work go beep they don't know if it
crashed or anything like that okay so
debris was eventually found but it was 2
hours later damn it crashed yeah 2 hours
later that thing is millions and
millions
have like a like a safety fault Auto AI
Land by itself I just deliver the news
so that just sounds so crazy for the
amount of technology that they have in
that plane they wouldn't have some sort
of like if you eject it cancels out the
uh stealth steal mod hey either somebody
[__] up or whoever created the stealth
is like they need a raise yeah cuz that
[__] hell they can't find it hella
stealy yeah so this missing fighter jet
was eventually found apparently 2 hours
after quote unquote mishap and they
won't dive into the mishap because you
know for the safety of the Integrity of
the investigation he was texting and
riding he was he was vlogging yeah he
like texting and [__] flying
[__] I bet you dude I saw um I don't
know too much detail about it but I did
see like a farmer coming out and talking
about it like yeah there was a crazy
noise and it went down that way I mean
it it looked like it was part of a
training
Squadron uh so this fighter pilot was
yeah safely was able to eject uh was
taken to a hospital just for like uh
evaluation stuff like that debris was
discovered about 2 hours Northeast of
Joint Base Charleston which is an air
base in North Charleston um they won't
provide further details but definitely
people in the media are also being like
like clean said you guys don't have
[__] technology to figure out on
radar where your [__] is they were
asking the public to please yeah they
said they're asking the public have you
seen this
F35 I feel like that's just like a a
common sense thing like if the pilot has
to eject from the plane and it's in
stealth mode then it automatically just
cuz it's it's all toggles dude you need
the other thing yeah but like it could
it could be like as you eject that
ejection toggles the the but what if
you're ejecting in like uh enemy
territory that's I was going to say if
it's if I play Devil's Advocate it would
be cuz you never want your enemy to
recover any of your aircraft or Weaponry
cuz they'll learn about your [__] that's
a good Devil's Advocate so that would be
the only reason why but they just give a
hell of [__] to Taliban anyway so
they're going to give it to manyways
yeah but maybe have the I don't know
have the ability because like this was
training right so you're obviously
within a scope of an area so I guess if
it's only training and you know you're
going to be within a scope of an area
have that safety feature they don't they
don't got GPS bro they need put a in it
they they're not tracking they have like
an air tag in it yeah yeah there's a
solution third party tracking pull my
find my Apple where's my F1 45 let me
play the sound so I can follow it and
find it cuz when the humans eject
there's parachute but the maybe the plan
should have parachute too yeah
they like yeah not so stealthy anymore
yeah I mean Bart when you was you know
uh spending time in the elite forces of
the US army or Marines uh what was some
of the most cool toys or technologically
like Advanced toys that you got a chance
to get your hands on get my hands on or
saw with my eyes saw with your eyes
obviously that's going to sound more
exciting then yeah why well cuz you
probably didn't touch anything you were
like [__] doing admin [__] and but I
saw so when I was passing on MREs I saw
some cool [__] we you see so at uh my
unit um third angle code they're like
they're like what Dawn does but at a
lower level so you you see a lot of
joint like uh air and call for fire type
[__] so you'll see guys going over there
calling coordinates and then later
you'll like [__] 2 minutes later like
is that like those giant backpacks with
a satellite and a phone on it yeah
they'll have like a like a radio and um
maybe they'll Mark a Target or they'll
shoot something to where they want the
target to be so there's times where I'm
like just sitting there and you see like
the whole training Evolution take place
so this is like covering maybe three
football fields and you just see these
[__] Jets come in and just like the
movies the Jets come and then literally
after the Jets leave like your [__]
frame that you're watching with your own
eyes it's
like and like everything's [__]
exploding you're like
America proud to be an American yeah
you're like when you see [__] like that
and then you see like other countries
training videos like I thought you were
calling no I thought you were calling I
was what's the number I forgot the
number you're like dudee we're going to
whoop everyone's [__] ass
dude yeah but do they got guys on roller
skates shooting yeah they got we don't
got that they got guys who can go on
monkey bars really well yep you think
they're still going to be an Army in
like 10 years if we have ai I don't even
know and robots and [__] I don't even
know and they got like zero recruitment
right now like no one's joining that
would be kind of tight though if we
enter an Arab the robot wars just for
our own fantasy just the idea of like
yeah they don't use human beings anymore
so it becomes like a battle between like
the minds of the best and brightest
scientists that create robots to fight
each other human beings with gamer
controllers operating the robots yeah
but it's all about creativity at that
point and style points you know what I
mean imagine like style you got to have
swag like it is what it is you know
you're going to build some robots and
some of them they don't have guns but
they have [__] Samurai eyes swords
and [__] like so that's one of two
things that's really cool the second
coolest thing I ever got to experience
is you go into this like um
it feels like it's made out of airplane
material like it's like some aircraft
metal thing and there's probably
insulation so it looks like they built
some secret office room in the middle of
nowhere and you get to be in a life-size
Humvee so like well actually it is a hve
so you're in a Humvee and then there's a
a mounted a mounted machine gun and it's
360 screens wow all around so it's like
a game it's a game and then so you're
driving through like Iraq or whatever
and there's buildings and people are
popping and you could change the machine
gun you can shoot the bad guys on screen
and that was pretty cool cuz it goes all
the way around and then that's when you
really realize oh [__] world uh war is a
360 thing when you're thinking you used
to play video games it's just you're
just thinking just going forward ah bad
guy but then now it's like oh [__] and
you got to turn around but you still got
to communicate with the driver and keep
going so there's like you you see how
much teamwork is involved and they have
all these like trash cans in the humy
because everyone's throwing up cuz
you're getting car sick even though
they're technically not not moving
that's probably like the those two are
like the coolest things I've probably
experienced that's crazy in the notary
holy [__] you just blew my mind with the
[__] everybody's throwing up yeah
yeah that Tripp me out I was like 360
gun cool dude you're like ginger ale
just in case just settle their tummy
give me ginger that really helps you
think they get used to the spins in in
the simulation thing oh I don't know I
think they should have that carnival
ride where you spin a lot built the
teacup ride at the military for training
cuz that's going to help with the spin
training I like seeing the celebrities
that go on Jets and they have so many
GeForce they make them pass out you ever
see that yeah I've seen that oh this is
so
fun you know two bit circus that one
arcade down in like Arts District area
yeah you know how they have like hella
[__] VR type stuff they do yeah so I
went I went there it was like me Mike
and like two of our other homies we went
there we're drinking a little bit too
but I wouldn't blame the drinking we we
paid for the [__] VR thing where you
you put on the headset and you sit in
one of those like uh digital humy type
stuff it's techno futuristic digital War
thing right but same thing and the crazy
part is uh when you turn visually and
you turn with like the gun and stuff so
does your thing kind of rotates too so
you get an actual feeling of that so
you're turning around and then one by
one I just like started hearing
everybody start tapping out like people
had like we couldn't even finish the
game I started feeling weird too right
by the time I get out out of all four of
us two guys fully threw up wow from
being [__] motion sickness yeah from
VR and then when we went outside one of
the guys who threw up in the bathroom
also threw up next to his car again and
the rest of we were done for the night
like there was no more hanging out cuz
everybody was just like kind of green
that only that only happens that only
happens because of the frame rate or
like the the speed of the thing it's
just like a low what this guys talking
about happens in real life yeah in the
simulation people were throwing up well
the simulation still it's still a screen
and stuff oh yeah like real humpies 360
stuff people for real have like trash
can no I don't no no that I think that
you wouldn't cuz you're like it's real
life now yeah it's normal so that means
they need to upgrade that tght just
making people that's why V isn't a thing
yet you got to get Sony to make those
screens that [__] is tight y'all are
y'all getting the The Vision Pro Apple
Vision Pro I'm getting that's like
$3,500 what's Apple Vision Pro nothing
to this guy you can do payment plans
[__] oh you going to get it for us what
is that it's crazy so it's this uh it's
this VR headset that they're oh I don't
like VR it's not VR it's it's AR so you
put it on and you see everything
normally right but then you'll see like
a a hologram basically and there's no
remotes you just do this like you can
put it down and you just tap and you
look everywhere you look is where the
cursor is pretty much so you just so
cameras are reading your retinas yeah so
it understands where you're at and they
just partner with like Disney plus like
this is going to be like think of like
ready player one but like with apple bro
it's going to be nuts that's going to be
wild yeah cuz the VR stuff is is already
pretty cool and now your retina is
completely scanned yeah that's cool I
mean it already is they already got it
everywhere else they got my face unlock
everything you guys get ios 17 yet that
[__] trippy what is it the new iOS they
got some new stuff on there what's some
new TI [__] it's on auto update but it
doesn't auto update this more of an
accessibility feature but you can read
150 messages in order for them to learn
your voice so that you can like automate
your voice so like let's say you're
losing your voice you can't speak you'd
be able to type things and in your voice
I mean it's not perfect but in your
voice it works pretty well wao that's
crazy sh [__] I don't want them to say
things that I didn't say it's for people
like Val Kilmer you know what I mean
whoa yeah that's
[Music]
true